fabrice epelboin merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation en direct sur rt france
alors l'utilisation de drones le conseil
d'état avait déjà émis un avis
défavorable qu'est ce qui coince
finalement avec son utilisation tout
simplement la constitution le respect de
la vie privée des données de base qui en
ce moment sont chamboulées donc très
probablement évoluer dans un avenir très
proche
alors justement si si le ministre de
l'intérieur avec un arrêté
gouvernemental décide d'encadrer le
traitement des données personnelles
recueillies l'utilisation des drones
pour identifier les délinquants pourrait
être possible ça poserait plus de
problème dans ces cas là c'est bien cela
il ya plein d'autres problèmes qui sont
bien plus rêver des victoires que la
constitution pour les drones typiquement
on a un problème de base à paris mais
pas que qui sont les goélands c'est
totalement incompatible avec les drones
la faune de paris les oiseaux notamment
absents sont pas compatibles avec les
drones les drones ont une durée de vie
très limitée
par ailleurs ça ne vous aura pas échappé
on est dans une période épidémique on
est tous censés porter des masques et
ses masques road impossible
l'identification
donc il ya des problèmes beaucoup plus
matérielle est beaucoup plus concret que
la constitution
mais déjà la concession devrait être un
frein assez rédhibitoire
l'idée c'est que tout ça ne constitue
guère qu'un épisode de communication
politique plus qu'une des réelles
intentions
ça n'est pas en l'état de la nature à
paris de l'écosystème parisien et de
tout un tas de grandes villes et de la
constitution et des contraintes
technologiques ça n'est pas possible
aujourd'hui celle sera demain mais ça
n'est pas possible aujourd'hui
par contre c'est un déchet d'annonce
intéressant et ça lève le voile sur un
projet de société
tu dis dans ce dossier justement à
propos de ce projet de société éventuel
la commission nationale de
l'informatique et des libertés la cnil
quand elle se positionne aujourd'hui la
cnil et c'est son rôle en général se
positionne contre ce type de projet
après la cnil ne peut pas bloquer pas
tel projet elle a un poids encore mais
il est très relatif alors vous le disiez
les drones finalement pour identifier
délinquance est compliquée avec les
goélands à paris notamment avec le port
du masque aussi précisément aujourd'hui
les forces de l'ordre est ce qu'elles
ont d'autres moyens légaux pour utiliser
les outils numériques pour identifier
les délinquants je pense notamment à
toutes ces vidéos 1 qui peuvent être
diffusés sur les réseaux sociaux où tu
ta qu'elles peuvent se saisir des vidéos
pour faire des investigations et ensuite
constituer un dossier qui sera ensuite
instruit par la justice les forces de
l'ordre font ça dès à présent le
problème c'est une question de moyens
notamment pour récolter ces informations
et puis pour constituer des dossiers qui
ensuite on passe à un autre problème de
moyens qui sont les bons gars de la
justice rappelle qu' on allait l'une des
justices témoins finances et du
continent européen
et que le problème principal se situe au
niveau de cette incapacité de la justice
à faire face à un nombre de cas à
traiter qui est considérable pour
conclure la flotte de drones que possède
la préfecture de police de paris elle
sert à quoi aujourd'hui au fond elle
sert à tester à expérimenter et à
avancer vers ce projet de société qu'on
nous destine à travers ce type d'annoncé
on peut trouver l'utilisation intensive
de drones par des forces de l'ordre dans
tout un tas de deux séries et de romans
de science fiction
on va très clairement en l'état des
choses vers ce type de société de
surveillance totale de l'espace public
ça a commencé souvenez vous il ya moins
d'un an avec la londe alterne l'idée que
les caméras vidéo vidéo coin de la rue
pourrait elle aussi identifié qui vous
être comprendre ce que vous faites et
éventuellement prendre des sanctions
là encore effet d'annoncer la
technologie dell n'en est pas à ce stade
mais malgré tous ces effets d'annoncé
nous permettre de toucher du doigt ton
très concrète l'avenir que nous prépare
ce gouvernement merci beaucoup fabrice
epelboin d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes ancien niant à
sciences po spécialiste des réseaux
sociaux